please sir it's your birthday oh man
god bless titties day he gave me the
gift of a little sister and a part of
you to be Lisa it's your birthday happy
birthday Lisa I wish you love a good
will I wish you praise joy I wish you
everything your heart this side you said
your first kiss buh-bye oh that song is
ruined now it's ruined now that last
line hmm yeah just like my first kiss
[Laughter]
because a documentary is funny I'm just
laughing because it's just so ridiculous
yeah so we're just gonna get right into
this what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of genius brain podcast
and you guys already know we had to get
in on this real fast pissed because so
first of all the whole dot the r kelly
thing happened right and then after the
whole our kelly thing happened there's
this they were just waiting for the
Michael Jackson documentary we got
Khalid boy with this today yeah man it's
it's a rough time to be a light-skinned
black dude curly hair right now I'll
tell you that I saw the damn comets as
he was going down yeah like a brillo pad
oh that was racist
wait Robison you're wrong for that road
guys if you guys haven't seen this
already there's been this HBO
documentation and basically all the
allegations about him being a sexual
predator now prior to this now I got to
really learn how to do some research
before I adamantly defend somebody this
is the second time I've defended a
sexual harasser who's first one Bill
Cosby
yeah and I'll and I back to Bill Cosby
with the quickness and I was I was wrong
well yeah then people say that still
hasn't been proven but I think when 87
women come out you pretty pretty bad
numbers so this whole docu-series so
well I was so I just got back from Vegas
and clubs in Vegas Khalifa's texted me
that yo did you see this HBO document
seen it yet cuz I you know number one I
love Michael Jackson he doesn't man I
love Michael Jackson everybody wanted to
be MJ growing up yeah man
and so like this whole time like when I
hear about somebody trying to slander
his name I'm just kind of like I always
brush it off a little bit you know just
because everybody wanted to dance like
him everybody wanna be like him and for
me specifically like I just remember
when he was on his last tour before he
passed away
we me my best we're gonna buy tickets
and then he passed I forgot what the
reason was
how you died how he died what was the
drug I forgot I was also kind of drunk
over to that doctor got you got
sentenced Oh after that really mm I
think I forgot that doctor's name I
forgot how much you want to bet he
touched his butthole oh man this is
gonna be rough no not for me this oh man
I am so nervous
yo so would you watch the docu-series is
so interesting because number one I
remember uh from the cases Macaulay
Culkin adamantly denying that Michael
Jackson touched him said he did not
touch it because there was no sexual
relations between me and that like
skinny man and I just he was just my
friend
he said like screaming yes ultralights
kid that problem a didn't really happy
yeah I mean we were watching it it was
so weird because like I just it just
kept getting worse and worse and worse
yeah the way they've really developed
the family and their relationship and
you got to like feel for this family
like they're almost a part of this
family and then here comes Michael
Jackson larger than life
and everything seems dope at the
beginning and then the grooming process
starts he groomed them that was the
interesting part because everything
seems so innocent right right and these
parents and the reason why I give these
parents a lot more slack than the
r.kelly parents cuz the art Kelley
parents knew it they knew about him
pissing on that girl they knew about the
golden showers they knew about all that
[ __ ] about him just walking around with
a bag of cookies and every high school
yeah
Lea McDonald's some surprise yeah yeah
they knew about all that stuff and they
didn't care with Michael Jackson was a
little different right yeah because he
just was he was on the scent of his like
really huge start worldwide stardom in
comparison to like our Kelly like like
you said like everyone knew that and his
certificate his marriage to Aaliyah and
that weird thing so yeah all the
scandals were out so it was kind of
weird with Michael Jackson like well it
wasn't weird because for them it's more
like when I was watching it all I could
think about was Michael Jackson seemed
like a really good guy that cared about
the kids right that's what it seemed
like anyways right so he would have the
kids come out and they would dance on
stage and that he would take them
backstage of fire you guys are probably
upset because this you know sounds like
a joke but if you saw the documents is
not a joke like legit it was so weird
and like I'm watching this thinking to
myself like number one okay first of all
if you guys haven't seen this cliff
Michael Jackson talking about how a lady
saw his face clip be talking about from
the interview that Martin Bashir did
like in 2003 and it's like living with
Michael Jackson you get to go to
Neverland Ranch and see Michael as a
normal human being but as you know this
guy was not it's not there was just one
part that cracked me up because I guess
like in this
in this interview I guess Michael is
opening up about number one how he felt
about his image growing up and you know
as we all know Michael changed the color
of his skin you know got you know facial
reconstruction with the nose and
everything else knowing that so he's
basically telling the story about how
this lady basically called him ugly now
[ __ ] laughs it's just the way it
happened so he's telling the story how
he was at the airport and when he was at
the airport this lady recognized him
because the people around them
recognized the Jackson 5 and then one of
the ladies was like yo where's Michael
Jackson where's my where's Michael
Jackson there's somebody was like that's
Michael Jackson right there and she
looks at Michael's face it goes like why
would you do that to a little kid he was
like 12 at the time then he I guess he
had like pimples on his face cuz he was
going to puberty
yeah the first thing she does she looks
at this 12 year olds kids face it goes
that's cold man that's so cold I could
kinda see like how he got messed up from
it yeah you know it's just like I want
to meet that lady I want her to come out
and have her own docu-series the lady
it's just wet around just calling little
kids ugly ugly she's wait that's so man
I so extreme that's so extreme well yeah
I mean his image and I was a bit of like
a bit illegal I guess like that's that's
where you you had the the skin
discoloration right yeah and he was
making an argument in that case about
like how what about the white people who
go out and get tans and no one says I
think about that so why can't I and then
he went back on his word and said like
God gave him Villa like
and kind of was a blessing for him
because he wanted to be less black or as
I would say or as I took it you want to
be less like his dad because he was
compared a lot to his dad image wise and
his dad said he hated his nose right
yeah it was huge yeah I don't like your
big old black nose yeah big nose and
then he just hated his nose ever since
and just made it as small as possible
yeah yeah he is dead and that was the
toughest part about that other interview
with Martin oh yeah Martin Bashir just
saying like how I think it's widely
known Joe Jackson was a very evil man
terrible terrible person beat the [ __ ]
out of the out of the Jacksons and made
sure they were perfect on the dance
moves especially Mike and the Jermaine
was supposed to be the star but the mom
was like no I think MJ's gonna be the
star and Joe didn't believe it and lo
and behold did you watch that it wasn't
a docu it wasn't a documentary but it
was like a remake of Michael Jackson's
life oh yeah with frickin uh MTV I think
it was on MTV yeah yeah you're the only
thing I remember from that is when that
fool did that spin in his head caught on
fire that customer that's the only thing
I remember throughout that all true
you don't member the only thing I
remember for that from that series was
Angela Bassett Lana mom and I remember
the the meaning behind the song Ben
remember he'd like befriended that rat
in the kitchen Oh kiss doffing killed
that rat
he's like Ben I forgot bit I don't
forgot how that song goes but that songs
about that I read you know what's crazy
to cuz if you guys watched the r.kelly
docu-series our Kelly wrote you are not
alone for Michael Jackson that's right
he did that's crazy it's too much man
both the more abused by family members
I'm not sure if Michael Jackson was
sexually abused but he was abused by his
father Yeah right right right yeah yeah
yeah I don't know if
sexually abused I don't think so but I
know he was he was verbally and
physically abused by his dad anytime
definitely messed him up yeah because
the whole thing that people would talk
about what Michael Jackson was he liked
being around kids because his childhood
was taken away so he was never allowed
to be a child so that's I think that's
how either people were justifying his
relationship with children and you know
when you say it like that it does make
sense since but man you really created
this big monster out of it just enabling
that yeah and you know when you when you
kind of step back and you look at it he
always had a kid around him no matter
what and that was basically his [ __ ]
grooming his muscle
[Laughter]
little little [ __ ] toys yeah and I
would have never thought that I just
would have thought he was the coolest
guy on earth and that's why all these
kids would flock around him like you
know I want to be that kid that's around
Michael Jackson all the time and so I
think that's why kids like him because
he's like he was the cool adult that
would let kids hang out not even other
adults right it's so hard to see that in
hindsight now because like like I was
saying earlier like being seven years
old and seeing Mike on MTV dancing and
the glove and like performing it's just
like he was just larger than life just
like a like a God you know and I could
imagine like I was seven years old
Michael Jackson held my hand like yeah
dude yeah just friends just friends dude
you know what threw me off was kind of
how slowly he did he was very meticulous
nebula yeah right so it wasn't like he
had the kids and all of a sudden the
parents were there and then he went into
the pears they hey I need y'all to leave
the room will quick because we gotta
practice our dance moves T don't grab
this kid yeah king of the carnival then
but he wouldn't do that he would first
what had them over for a second he would
start having he would spend the night at
their house right playing toys and he
even developed a relationship with the
first guy through his parents and his
and even his mom was like no Michael
Jackson was like one of my kids I would
do his laundry like what the [ __ ] aren't
you guys like similar in age
talking about lady but telling do zone
yeah so she would do his laundry making
meals they would hang out but slowly
things started to progress and he was
very very I say smart with his predatory
plan but how do you develop that that's
just so crazy and conniving like it is
conniving it's so like yeah oh the way
he did it was so it seemed like such a
textbook and executed to perfection cuz
he did it with so many kids yeah cuz he
would do the whole you know I'm coming
over
let's spend the night let's hang out
which initially is kind of sounds like
from like cuz he said like he's like a
fourteen-year-old kid that was always an
argument that a kid would have is like
well it's like Michael why are you
you're 44 why are you hanging out with a
14 year old and a 14 year old be like
he's like a 14 year old and like the kid
would justify that so Scott Yuri see the
brainwashing like it's almost like
normalizes it he would give them like a
script like r.kelly like yeah they would
almost have a script and then the then
they started out in the documentary they
were also saying that I forgot who it
was with I think it was with Wade Rob
Wade which one they would do the drills
that was with James Oh James pretty sure
James Jimmy James I mean it was maybe to
call him Jimmy yes yeah yeah so Jimmy
would do the drills with him it's like
okay okay so when somebody buses through
this door I have to do the voice by the
way door I got it
you got to get up and get up close real
fast and then you win points or some
[ __ ] like yeah and you get that little
Mickey Mouse go ring and she saw at the
jewelry store
he did that with Jimmy yeah he did the
fake proposal yeah that's so [ __ ]
weird yeah there's a seven-year-olds
like if you're you're you're [ __ ]
idols telling you like if you tell your
parents that this is happening then we
we will be destroyed oh it wasn't even
you or me us it was like that as a kid
you want to keep that secret yeah those
kids are pretty good at keeping secrets
you know so it's like man the whole
psychological adji behind it is so
interesting
because I'm trying to figure out not
only were the kids just in awe of
Michael Jackson the parents were too
yeah and they just couldn't suspect
Michael Jackson of doing something like
that
yeah and it's weird because they would
you know when they were interviewing the
mom or the dad they were just talking
about how in all they were that Michael
Jackson would choose their kid yeah you
can't see a Condon icon yeah it's great
he's just like what maybe they just did
it
they just didn't even see it and so I
mean there wasn't a mom that was talking
about how you know she did find it weird
how every time they started getting
closer they get booking the rooms
further and personal way it like pick up
a red flag yeah like they were in Paris
and then you know Michael would be like
oh they couldn't get you a suite next to
mine so you're just gonna be a couple of
doors down and then they would go to
Jared they would go to Germany and then
oh we couldn't get you on the same floor
so we had to get you on the next floor
because we can't have you in a small
room that's the only available suite I
want you to be comfortable and they
would just go there they would go to
like I don't know like Italy yeah when
they're in Italy they'd be okay well I
just gotta send you off on a boat
[Laughter]
because there's nowhere else you can
sleep there's no hotels left in Italy
yeah so have fun [ __ ] man that's a voice
go outside he's a piece if you come back
I'm a queue you count to a thousand yeah
I don't know maybe is this from the
other the surgery he just can't see you
can't see the CH sound yeah
that's why they couldn't suspect it me
to know who he was attacking right
how can you just be a parent and then
like I guess you know what people say
like when you have a child it changes
everything like you become more
protective and want to make the best for
your child but then I kind of not I just
can't imagine about sleeping with an
adult with an adult like that are like
adult even if it's like the motes person
aye aye aye Idol ok well let's put you
in a scenario right so you have a you
have a 5 year old kid his name is Colby
little Colby is dancing in front of uh
sure and uh she's like yo that's the
neck cancer ok yeah in this skinny ass
legs yeah taking that picture in the
sauna nothing about the yeah what's he
have again what kind of STD only the STD
that's the rumor
ok pop this yeah everybody that's true
ok let's go back to ok let's see who
somebody you you you really [ __ ] with
right now right now
Idris Elba no no you know what I would
say like the most respectable figure
like like a Barack Obama Barack Obama
yeah so weird long pause her somewhere
else like someone have an ST mark I
don't know where I heard it but like
imagine the president the United States
saying like hey come over to my house
and Pasadena okay cool it's like make
sure you bring your kid Kobe SEC okay
cool yeah but Kobe's a big fan it's like
oh hey I'm glad you had some a good time
at this dinner how about you know you
let Coby us sleepover it's like okay
it's like how babysitting my bed like
that yeah yeah it's like you know
they're sleeping same bit like what I
just don't I don't see it and that's
what the argument about like the whole
exploring and trying to blackmail and
like I could see from that angle but cuz
I could also see if the President of the
United States said hey while she left
your kid spend the night in the White
House and I'm like oh [ __ ] why don't my
Secret Service is everybody around here
right I'm not thinking about like
[ __ ] everybody running the train on
my kids booty huh that's not what I'm
thinking about correct I'm just thinking
that he's gonna spend a night in one of
the presidential rooms and they're gonna
sleep in a separate bed he's gonna wake
up you don't have a presidential
breakfast right have some president
presidential luncheon crackers and have
some presidential water
yeah I'm not thinking about all that all
that other stuff but if the president
said said well let's have him sleep in
my bed then I'd be like Kobe was like
hey I got to sleep in Brock's bed hello
what yeah you slept in his bed right
exactly
I'd be pissed right well ask questions
like summit accent like the parents
though did had that same thing that the
r.kelly parents had oh you saw that CBS
interview thing no what's that
occasionally like a six-minute 8 minute
like they had a rebuttal like they
interviewed the parents and so like they
called the daughter afterwards and was
like hey this is dad or this is mom
eating so I go hi and then they had I
think it was a the one that was not
talking the most in the interview okay
her low sister jumped on the phone it
was like hey and then that kind of
stalled the sister mmm in not delivering
the expected script that she's been
delivering to her parents
yeah a time so it's kind of like a
moment for the parents a moment of hope
to make them believe that it wasn't too
late to save her daughter oh because up
to this point it was like you could feel
like I keep calling him Robert I can't
even call Mark Kelly anymore you're
Robert now bro yeah like Robert the
monster he's just right there making
sure that she's you know on script and
making it sound normal you know even
with his case like with Robert with
Robert Kelly he's his home so you're not
even you're not even you're not even the
same man yeah
when Gayle King was interviewing him
that [ __ ] was wild man that bull had an
emotional breakdown you talk about a man
that could not compose himself to save
his life yeah she was just yo Gil King
was super composed you talk about a lady
that knows what's up she was like I'm
not gonna let this guy take like take
control or like especially break me now
you don't scare me that's what she
looked like missile this little Texas we
say they doesn't our Kelly look like
he's making an album hey I wasn't far
off man there's videos out now oh really
yeah people were like freaking out I'll
tune that [ __ ] that's like ours if I
knew how to do that [ __ ] mi rhoi trying
to take my life yeah you can't help but
make music yeah he was rhyming
everything T I wish I know what he said
but he was rhyming he didn't know it
kill myself with the knife I think they
did it over the [ __ ] chaplet of
trapped in the closet
instrumental God dude it's perfect
all-kill he's like Superman out of shape
- I didn't realize that yeah kind of
yeah you could tell by his pants cuz
when he stood up his dress pants had
those tiger stripes it was I know
exactly what those are excited to get
those all the time on my pants man I
can't [ __ ] pants suit had those
feathers sharp bridges on it having
stretched so hard yeah I think the whole
when the one the whole raid was a raid
watt rock Wade Robbins were here I was
in here when he was talking when he
started getting into specifics about
them things that Michael Jackson to him
yeah it was wild you know what
Wade sounded like it will from what I
saw when he was talking about Michael
Jackson he sounded like he was talking
about an ex-boyfriend or girlfriend that
did him wrong
that's what Wade Robson slew yeah that's
right the way he was brainwashed yeah I
could see that that's that's that's the
feeling that I got from it which kind of
creeped me out and then Jimmy sounded
like the he's still in love with Michael
Jackson and he
like he misses the relationship that
they had yeah he definitely was sad when
he passed away it's like he felt like he
disappointed him yeah and then he was
looking at the engagement rings like I
know why are you keeping those things
yeah and he's looking at it like man I
miss those days when he would kiss me in
the mouth or something that's the face
that he look that's how much he said his
hand was shaking like he can't hasn't
touched him since like then um I don't
know maybe because I was looking in his
eyes and his eyes looked like he missed
Michael Jackson for sure oh yeah uh he
you know I'm not saying that I mean he
was super young so it was during a very
impressionable time I think the part of
me that shocked me was how when you
looked at their body language in their
demeanor and looked like they were
missing a huge part of their life it
didn't look like they hated him right
because in my mind I think if I got
older I would think okay you go I
obviously haven't been in their shoes
but I would think I I hate this man for
doing this to me at such a young age but
for Jimmy it seemed like I got frozen
yeah he was just like stuck like he
couldn't he was like almost trying to
figure out his old thoughts mm-hmm
mm-hmm yeah I mean it's coming I mean
that people complain or not complain but
like argue why didn't they come out with
this sooner it's like you can't you
can't get in their mind everyone is in
due time with how they process things
like my own was [ __ ] yeah you know like
being 32 and figuring out things that
weren't normal when I was seven yeah oh
[ __ ] that was not normal yeah now I'm 13
figuring that [ __ ] out you know and I
think Wade Robson he's like 34 or 35 you
know I'm not saying that I got you know
[Music]
that right no but my butthole thing yeah
I know that but yeah come to terms but
yeah I mean with Wade Robin do he was
talking about Michael Jackson would make
him bend over bro don't say it so he go
look at his mother
man said vary so graphic it threw me off
like I first of all number one let's
just talk about how Michael Jackson even
as let's just take away the sexual
predator part in general this his sexual
preferences are weird yeah as a human
being
aside from the the really glaring sexual
preference is very odd and sick he would
have him pegged over just so he go look
at the blood and when he said that my
jaw dropped I was like oh yeah man and
then with Jimmy
she said that he he would make Jimmy
know Jimmy would suck his nipple and
then he would go off into a corner and
jackoff I'm not laughing cuz like the
situation's funny I'm laughing because I
don't know what else to do cuz it's so
ridiculous yeah it's it's almost it's
ridiculous and it's infuriating because
what the [ __ ] like how do you process
that mm-hmm and this is what I'm talking
about his perversion got worse and worse
because when it first started off with
Jimmy he didn't he Jimmy from what they
said was that or what it sounded like
was Jimmy didn't perform sexual acts on
Michael Jackson Michael Jackson was
performing it on him because he said
that he usually he gave him gave him
head while he was sleeping and then he
would kind of test him what it sounded
like he would test his waters yeah so he
would do it while he was sleeping and
then when he woke up you would be like
hey so I uh I gave you oral sex and then
he would it almost sounded like he was
testing yeah totally how he would be
kissing the boundaries for sure yeah
definitely I mean even with James it's
funny because I try to remember their
names yeah I was like Dwyane Wade LeBron
James Wade James this makes no sense
but uh Jane said like that he you know
Michael and he didn't like it and
Michael started crying [ __ ] that's right
as a seven-year-old you're like my I at
all is crying because I didn't make him
happy
well not even that that's my best friend
yeah and this weird ceremony they had
like I don't wanna let him down so
I feel like Michael Jackson was even
crying he was he was having it up for
sure yeah he did it to Wade Robinson to
the fake crying but yeah but you're the
fake crying thing when like that he when
they found out that they were gonna go
to the Grand Canyon and Michael was like
ah this for last night I don't wanna I'm
gonna miss you guys the faxes he would
fax Wade Robinson every [ __ ] day
non-stop stop hey well he called in my
little one my little one my little one I
miss you
make sure you fax me tonight Oh Apple
head order the [ __ ] yeah it was like
what you do it let's do it get back over
here Apple here yeah read those peaches
over here Apple it which is sexy little
bird oh man and it was weird because I
think he was very precise with those
facts because it's said number one they
were pet names but if you read it and
you didn't know about his relationship
with these children it just sounded like
he was just having like fun
talk or something yeah cuz how I don't
know how old he was when they were 7
regardless it's still wrong had to be he
was either late teens or what 20 20
excuses toys who Michael Michaels
twenties right was he I had an idea or
maybe 30s maybe probably 30s yeah
because he was 44 ish when over 30 he
was 44 in in 2003 yeah I believe because
even regardless of him getting off you
know and having Neverland our Neverland
Neverland Ranch he was still having
sleepovers with kids he was having a
sleepover with multiple kids he was oh
like this yeah that's the crazy he
wasn't even loyal yeah that sucks
he was just sampling constantly from all
these little kids and then these kids
like Wade Robbins has started feeling a
certain way because as they started to
get older he started feeling less
attracted to them mm-hmm which is wild
so how did so for him it really is that
he was attracted first of all to only
young white boys I know he had a certain
flavor mm-hmm like if you notice in that
whole dock
it wasn't a single black man or Asian
kid yeah I don't know who the other kids
because that one kid kind of look yeah
yeah he also stated that Michael Jackson
never touched them right the one guy
[ __ ] ah the one that they testified
against and settled for 20 million that
guy became so traumatized I'm pretty
sure this is him you got so traumatized
that he got facial reconstruction or
like to change his whole face changes
whole face I think he'll change his name
and about a few months after Michael
Jackson passed away he shot herself in
the face after winning 20 million
dollars I believe so I'm pretty sure
yeah Jordan that's so [ __ ] wild
that's insane like all the kids that
were like the adults like Macaulay
Culkin I don't know I feel like 20
million dollars I can forget a lot of
things okay
pedophile watching this [ __ ] be like
okay okay you sure about that the ghost
of Michael Jackson you would never
forget this day you tell me right now
you did that video I need find out yeah
so the what we're ever see right now is
is somebody on instagram did know it
snapchat did the facetune thing and they
basically uh they swapped and they face
what Michael Jackson's face is you just
doing this stupid impression as though
he came back from heaven yeah to admit
his girl of course I [ __ ] those keys
oh man this conversation is on fire
there's so many there were so many just
inappropriate jokes that are coming out
from this right now just because like
number one like I said I'm one of those
people that adamantly defend it first of
all Jo Jo defended the hell out of
Michael Jackson really Jo Jo is the
biggest Michael Jackson fan on this
earth and when he went to Vegas mmm he
went to the Michael Jack
so he got the gloves the jacket
everything and he was wearing it for
like a month
Joe definitely would have been one of
those kids that got butt [ __ ] and it
would have just been too easy for
Michael yeah you definitely don't
realize see me through my yeah he's like
I am so uncomfortable like no no you
shall be your butthole Mike oh yeah
Joe's like one of those jelly no [ __ ]
dude I'm gonna take [ __ ] from nobody man
I just don't know how to feel about it
it comes the question that the whole
like artists and the personal whatever
is oh I can't listen to another Michael
Jackson thing ever oh you know it's hard
because like I I still catch myself
humming like r.kelly song me too out of
nowhere
like it was so this is so part of our
social fabric man like I remember making
my dad make me buy that or buy me that
play school actually didn't buy me that
[ __ ] I got that from a geez dad
a place called basketball court and then
[ __ ] playing I believe I can fly the
opening sequence so Space Jam you know
and having that music playing in the
background and I'm like [ __ ] jumping
5 feet from the couch to the you know
basket dunking it r.kelly man yo I
didn't think that there would be an
actual limit to for me anyways with the
separate the artist from the art and I
think I've reached my limit with our
Kelly and also Michael Jackson mm-hmm
which is wild to me man cuz I love
Michael Jackson man you are not alone
that's a double whammy yeah two people
two people that I'm disgusted every day
and to me to be honest with you Michael
Jackson's way worse cuz at least with
our Kelly like his lowest number was
like 14
Michael Michael Jackson would see a 12
year old kid to be like
[Music]
you too old yeah go to a junior high and
he'll be like y'all [ __ ]
oh well different yeah that pubes huh
look at you Greek JanSport backpacks you
like Voltron yes I'm saying so who's
worse now so is our Kelly we're sores uh
or is uh I'm not making a comparison
really yeah you are
I'm just saying cuz now I'm thinking
about it because number one I think of
how graphic the things that he did to
those little kids Michael for sure is
that like Michael is way worse just
because of the age yeah you know the age
bothers me I know I shouldn't be
affected and the people that are Kelly
whose lives he destroyed they were very
young too but we're talking about you
know 15 16 - [ __ ] 4 5 6 7 you know
what I mean right
and that [ __ ] blows my [ __ ] mind and
I think like the the the part with how
they set up a docu-series to where they
were talking about how he would perform
on them for some reason for me and I'm
like well at least he's not making these
kids do stuff to him you know right not
at least as anything's better or worse
but I'm just saying like maybe he had
some kind of like weird moral boundary
but he did not he was just grooming them
and later on the kids started performing
it to him hmm
which terrible yeah Robinson brought
that racist ass comment where he said
his hair felt like a brillo pad
[Laughter]
scotch-brite yeah it just like just
think the the the topic of pedophilia is
so hot right now and they're just so
obsessed with it and it comes at such a
high bubble right now it's burst for
sure I just don't know how it could be
fix since it's so taboo to talk about it
like talk about like I still
the uncomfortable thing to hear about
and I for me the only one the only thing
I can do to cope with it is just to
laugh because it's just it's such a
weird thing to hear Wade Robinson talk
about the specificities of what that man
would do to let me it didn't sit well
with my stomach but I do you remember
details like details like that at 7 or 8
no I don't which is crazy he remembers
all these small things like right like I
said like what he specifically made him
do because as a seven-year-old
seven-year-old is I'm like almost blank
yeah eight year old I could remember a
bit but seven I don't know that's such
an odd I don't know then again who was
like your big Idol at seven that did you
ever get to see like a person that she
really looked up to was excited
what great was that when I was in said
like five is kindergarten six is first
second grade probably in second grade I
don't remember [ __ ] from second grade
dude I don't remember first and second
at all
I remember kindergarten third grade you
ever like going like Disneyland or some
[ __ ] did you go to dinner uh-huh
what do we have here we have we had the
gold mining he would just they would
take us to Sutter's Fort and we would
mine for fares no like icons are like oh
we have to learn newscaster like he knew
that newscaster you're like oh you know
what we had Vallejo around the corner so
we had like six flags of [ __ ] and then
Great America so you didn't get hyped if
you saw like Bugs Bunny and [ __ ] you
know what I mean Michael Jordan you saw
Michael Jordan now I never saw him but
I'm saying somebody idolizing kid
Michael Jordan for sure I'm saying like
if you met like some like for me like
who comes to mind at seven I think I
went to like a mortal kombat like a
world tour thing anyone to like the
Honda they went to like the Honda Center
and I might do was Jack's
like I loved Jack's all the one black
dude yeah and the guy who was playing
jacks was like a came the machine off of
a key the machine stops hella familiar
yeah it may see master yes yes dude him
he played him so I was super [ __ ]
hyped yeah like I got the program waited
outside when he came out I was like oh
my god yeah like his gym shirt on and he
like his pants he
gym bag and he came out he had this like
his dreads he had like the red bandana
he came out he was like things were
coming out the show I was a girl my
favorite character he's like oh thanks
like do you do anything I'm like no I
can't do like Taekwondo or anything or
fighting by just really like I watch it
every Saturday
like I remember where I was in that
parking lot
which door he came through and I came to
the left side I knew like tsunamis
whatever the other Nami yeah do you
remember that dude that did the the the
yellow pants guy he kind of reminded me
of Luke King he would do the the scissor
kick yeah yeah yeah yeah Oh them like
yeah I remember all them coming through
that door and it's like a key man like I
just remember that interaction but the
machine yeah thank you machine and then
even going through like therapy and like
family stuff and like unearthing all
that stuff that I just kind of like
didn't even touch is that oh she got
that should happen I'm not recreating
and narrative I was like that actually
did happen I'm not trying to justify why
certain parts of my life are [ __ ] up
but that [ __ ] did happen I'm trying to
make sense of it so for a person who has
like who suffers from or is a pedophile
and they don't want come out right with
it like how do they if they come out and
say like I'm I like little boys like I
just did something wrong with me how do
we it's hard right take I wouldn't I
wouldn't even know like I wouldn't even
know how to address that I is it true
wait I don't know if it's like [ __ ] I
think also too you know how with with
psychiatrists hmm it's supposed to be a
safe place for you to be able to say
whatever but if it's something like that
they have to report you to the police
right and then you're like [ __ ] and
you're [ __ ] because there was the
seventh the seventh heaven guy was a
pedophile wasn't he [ __ ] yeah dude
pastor yeah the pastor serve in heaven
when I see y'all happy faces smiling
back at me seven
she was so bad tell my Jessica Biel dude
and I do with with chuck and Larry I do
oh yeah it was raining see she had the
multicolored underwear yeah Jessica Biel
I'm telling you man
she was bad bad as hell she's still with
Justin Timberlake right yeah well he
[ __ ] up for a hot minute and really
yeah yeah and then they got back
together you know somebody told me the
story about Justin and mind you this is
obviously not my story because this
didn't happen to me was to a girl but
she said that Justin would do this thing
where he wouldn't approach a woman what
he would do is that he would let's say
they were at a club he would be at the
club she's popping off and then he would
see a girl that he thinks is really cute
he wouldn't approach them he would get
his bodyguard to walk up to them right
hmm tell him what's up
and says yo Justin would like to talk to
you and he would hand them a disposable
cell phone hmm and give it to them
that's a you know like call Justin on
this phone and that's how they would
talk and link up and after that they
would just get rid of the cell phone or
some [ __ ] hmm this [ __ ] Wow
mmm yeah that's pretty well we took you
that I don't remember what you know yeah
yeah but somebody told me that's what he
does like he does that thing with like a
disposable cell phone or some [ __ ]
and then he would like to have his
bodyguards talk to them which I'm sure a
smart I said Wow
yeah I remember it was a note though
like a girl she was like two years older
than me she went to this trio's mall and
r.kelly was there I think it was either
the liquid maulvis through his mall and
he had the bodyguard like pass a note
and then her friends smart and like no
don't do that she's like whoa why it's
like it's [ __ ] hard Kelly like yeah
as musics banging but you know it's this
really another diehard Lea fans and then
she has like a very like African look I
mean there's like a saw oh I forgot what
song it is there's a song that sounds
very tribal and like
this day my friend thinks that songs
about her do you have any idea first of
all that full went to Africa do you have
your passport did you get your shots
would you like to come and Rob to
America yeah that's definitely not about
you he had a thing for young African
girls yeah they'd lost her [ __ ] mind
that's so funny like people will
manifest anything in their head yes they
could feel special yeah that's that
she's a prime suspect she would have
been she would've been it would be game
over she would have been locked up
I'm glad glad she had some good friends
to stir yeah that's smart do she
actually did have good friends like yo
don't do it under smart yeah I was like
a Nisshin was hot but don't do it you
know how that is like what the other
girls like Ezreal or whatever her name
is I know the last name her last name is
savage that's a dope ass last name hmm
one of the girls that lives with our
Kelly like she was the one that's just
like it's a funny thing because like you
survived Mark Kelly like there was
footage of them both of them like
singing and wanted to be musicians and
artists and have you know our Kelly
mentor them and in his interview they're
like we never wanted to sing our parents
forced us to like they said go this
would be a great opportunity to work
with our Kelly and if you can try to
sleep with him and get it recorded so
that if things backfire we can blackmail
them and that's their argument that's
the story that's sticking to right now
which is like their parents said that
their parents are that like so it's a
it's a whole new story line to this art
Kelly [ __ ] and the kids are saying that
that was a person
yeah see but both of them they were
saying like they both have different
parents but the way that the other girl
was agree with the other girl seemed
like oh yeah that's the story that our
Kelly tells to do it like yeah yeah yeah
and then Gail was like wait not get yeah
get wait Gail yeah Gail's wait a minute
are you saying wait your parents like Oh
my parents did it too like it was like
they were on a script for sure oh yeah
it's interesting to watch and she has
his whole [ __ ] breakdown and she's
crying and says like people who
understand we
each other like there's people out there
who are in relationships with multiple
people like why can't we and girls like
this is different situations I guess you
don't know you understand that
brainwashing is wild man yeah yeah
abducted in plain sight I haven't seen
that but well that that one's weird too
man and like I said that thing is so
weird and is so uncomfortable and so
inappropriate I'm laughing the
inappropriate I heard about something
like he kidnapped her and made her feel
like they had like a little speaker box
or some [ __ ] like that okay so number
one I didn't watch the whole thing all
right this is abducted in plain sight
but there was this guy that basically
he's a [ __ ] freak and he's kind of a
psychopathic genius so he would
basically kind of meld into these
communities and it's like very innocent
human beings they they wouldn't suspect
anything of him he was like the town
hero the town everything and so with
this young girl he somehow duped her and
abducted her by getting her to believe
that aliens were speaking through a
speaker box and that the store I can't
remember exactly just because I was so
freaked out but basically their victim
they had to reproduce they had to have
sex and reproduce to save like the human
race or something like that and he would
do that through like a fake radio bomb
how old was she she was super super
young and for her she felt like there
was a duty she had this duty to fulfill
hmm right and I'm talking about yo it
was opening up to some weird [ __ ] this
is the part that I laughed at that I
shouldn't have laughed at but it's just
because it you know it's current it was
so crazy but he somehow duped one of the
guys in the town to suck his dick oh I
dare but it wasn't that her dad I'm not
sure guys how they like how he set it up
it was her dad and then like he slept
with her mom oh well I was pretty sure
yeah he was like you know what my
relationship with my wife or something
is really bad and I'm just really
sexually frustrated man can you suck my
dick the guy was like I guess and then
lo amoled he started sucking his dick
and then when he was talking about he
goes I gave him fellatio and he started
tearing out oh yeah but I started
laughing
cuz like I'm trying don't even know why
I'm laughing is because I don't think
there's a single human being on earth as
a heterosexual man and tell me about his
what his problem with his life
yo man Mario's being a [ __ ] dude so
like the other day she first of all we
haven't had sex in a minute
I don't even find unattractive at all I
just haven't been able to get my nut off
man yeah how innocent are these people
that tip rose it was a disease I don't
know a snake business I don't know but I
think everybody was talking about how it
was a very small town and that people
just everybody trusted everybody like
did that extent we're talking about
whatever we as Americans think about
Canadians being nice magnify that times
10 man I'm in Idaho it was weird because
when he kidnapped her and because she
believed in this whole narrative of the
whole alien race thing happening she
adamantly believed that she loved this
guy like she loved him and she defended
him to till the end so like I guess
people would ask after you were
kidnapped but she was know like we just
went on a trip and she would just
develop this whole story either by
herself or it was corroborated with him
but she stuck with it because she feel
like she had a duty to protect the earth
isn't that that's the craziest thing
I've ever heard in my life
you have to be so sheltered and so
exactly cuz as a ten year old kid or
something like that
I forgot how old she was alright I when
somebody started speaking through a
speaker though that's an alien and
basically now we got a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of here do think you it do you
remember like those those weird-ass
alien specials on like channel like Fox
got my X Files it was X no was that - it
but like do you remember how much ghost
story scared you at ten all ghosts gory
story sales scare me now like oh [ __ ]
okay buddies remember like anything was
possible like though that homie that
that
FOB homie from Philippines yeah tell me
like some scary stories from the
Philippines like it's just like you know
he's half body's Walker floating in the
air I'm like what the [ __ ] and I'm ever
been like devastated and wanted to sleep
in the same bed with my parents so like
I could see why that girl would freak
out and just believe everything just was
saving it yeah we should like the only
chili he would I think he can't have
like oh he drugged her yeah yeah so she
was probably a very just weird like
lucid state and that probably [ __ ]
flew instance right how she was thinking
to do people are weird man the seventh
heaven guy who else Wow [ __ ] who else
was funny is benefit are Kelly seven
heaven dude Michael Jackson Michael
Jackson my band teacher your band
teacher yo so in high school there was
his girl who had a relationship with the
I don't know the exact terminology the
headmaster chief of JROTC right and so I
should you not though it was his other
dude his name was Jerry and he actually
went out with her now Jerry was just
really awkward guy it's very like just
imagine a extremely God skinny asian
dude braces just just do we be looking
as hell bowl cut and he was just that
point Dexter that would always point out
what everything that you're doing wrong
he would be the excuse me teacher we
didn't get our extra credit that was
that he was that type of dude so he
actually went out with this girl right
and she looked like a very normal girl
so I used to make jokes not about not
about Jerry but I like her I would be
like yo how does she get all those like
[ __ ] like JROTC bandit has she been
there as long as you Jerry so what's she
been doing might be after school and we
would make I would make jokes like that
right lo and behold [ __ ] the news
pops up right so she got caught at this
place called Norman water Norman Waters
Park in Sacramento having sex with that
chief master dude in the car before
school would start
and I that joke came true and yo that
dude Jerry was devastated man I mean I I
think I don't know why he was devastated
because they weren't together don't
understand crash yeah maybe he still
really liked her yeah but you do that
happen and I guess like during my same
school floor in high school there was a
teacher that got beta dance which he
basically got [ __ ] what was the the
2020 guy [ __ ] Chris Hanson here Chris
Anthony got Chris Hanson by the the
Sheriff Department and so they pretended
to have a different online alias and as
a young person and he was communicating
with that girl and they rendezvous at a
hotel and the cops busted him and
arrested him is it it goes back to that
point of like these televisions or
whatever these specials about catching
the predator like how it's so glorified
and so going back to the people who like
it haven't acted on these impulses and
know they're wrong yeah like if it
scares them into not confessing or in
that confessing but seeking help like
that's what I'm really intrigued with
and this this this scent I guess this
age number that we put in society I
wonder how recent of a construct that is
just because number one Elvis Elvis his
wife was like 14 - yeah like we don't
talk about that yeah let's talk about
Elvis man [ __ ] I'm tired man it's tough
dude are Kelly and Michael Jackson man
then Elvis Presley had that [ __ ] - yeah
a lot of them do surrounded and if we
even go even further back back in the
day like people had these arranged
marriages with young young women they
were in there 14 13 or 12 and they would
end up having kids or you know I think
kids super young yeah yeah I think like
even if you go back into like Greek or
Roman history there was like young boys
that were just [ __ ] all the time or
some [ __ ] like then so I wonder if it's
like a recent contract that they put
this age gap like you can't have but
even for me
like I'm not a true I would never be
attracted to somebody that young they
look disgusting to me like they look and
smell disgusting mm-hmm like there's no
if there's any for
you know kids that are listening to this
right now just know that you smell
something nice huh I'm saying this as a
guy who used to be 14 yes well we we
smell we smelled like backpack sweat and
Cologne that didn't make sense you know
yo I wonder though if kids do smell
better now just because the internet
probably you know gets them to look
better and [ __ ] because I know we didn't
have that when we were in junior high
and stuff we had to figure out how to
dress just by how other kids dress so we
all look like kids sorry Tom I suppose
me yeah in high school these kids don't
like kids anymore they look like they're
trying to be adults hmm yeah I tried to
lessen guessing game and I stuck with my
[ __ ] uniform you know uniforms in
like elementary school yeah so
prohibition like most school yeah but
then I was like now I'm the athlete so I
could just wear shorts and a shirt my PE
shirt all the time yeah yeah yeah kids
have swag man it's weird man I say you
kids better watch out man you over here
just wear makeup is [ __ ] people gonna
snatch you up you better watch out
there's a lot of creepy ass people in
this world man yeah I don't trust I
don't trust people at all kind of aggro
but is it being acting groans just find
your self-expression I don't [ __ ]
know do my getting into a [ __ ] I want my
kid I I want my kid to be a kid yeah
that's what I want I wonder I don't know
what that is but that's gonna look like
in the next five years or whatever
because I get scared yeah I get scared
that they want to grow up too fast or
they they're just too busy trying to be
something that they're not as I'm in
their control yeah that's why I think
likes what Dave Chappelle just moved out
to the butt [ __ ] of nowhere she's like
in Illinois yeah so his kids can be kids
yeah you know and well they want to be
adults they can be adults and I feel
like that that that that area where
these children are allowed to be kids
have disappeared we're in the wards
really short now because he because they
they want to be something that they're
not or they feel like they have to be
something they have to be the people
that they idolize and there's a fast
away from them to get that knowledge on
how to be an adult
yeah cuz YouTube is wild so instead yeah
they can teach themselves like tutorial
tutorials all day I just try figure that
out by yourself that's cool so I'm
saying like even when I see these kids
who are young choreographers and young
guests and they're dancin like some sexy
has music is [ __ ] and then twerking I'm
like yeah yeah it's like it's like
eleven year old choreographers like oh
my it's like dope you could dance but
what the [ __ ] are you doing right why
are you dancing like that just [ __ ]
popping the [ __ ] you [ __ ] like ten
dude right
I would I would 300 kicked my kid in the
face [ __ ] you child yeah I never get
those when those videos pop up on
Instagram and just like these kids and
like still I doesn't [ __ ] it's like yeah
they're doing my mic torques and
dropping it and like yeah I think you're
make you're like doing like the mating
call like they're like and there's
adults teaching these kids yeah I was
watching this dude
what was his song but it was mad graphic
yeah they be either a cardi B song or
something like that but it was like a
super graphic song and you know they
bleeped out the curse words or whatever
but the song is already sexually
suggestive but it was he's a really
popular choreographer his name is Matt
stephania and he was teaching this young
girl how to do this dance and in my mind
I'm thinking yo dance is a form of
expression or whatever and people call
me old-fashioned or whatever but I'm not
I'm pretty sure I'm not trying to have
any kid express themselves hyper
sexually at a very young age I
personally yeah you know I think it's a
little much and I think when adult
teaches a kid that it's a little odd for
me like I don't know the dude he might
be a great guy and I'm pretty sure his
intentions weren't bad but for me as an
adult when I see that I think now I look
at him like why are you a Michael
Jackson now alright the [ __ ] you doing
teaching this kid like these all these
sex because it looks mad innocent that
was now it has me second-guessing [ __ ]
right hmm by the way I'm not slandering
him I'm just using him as an example I'm
like I said I'm pretty sure he's just
it's just music and dance to him it's
just a form of expression but because of
this document documentary and in these
documenting what's the motivation behind
this yeah I'm just trying when I think
it was James when he was saying that uh
his
you know you start swelling and like it
was a new thing for him I was like damn
did I get my first boner around seven
eight years like I don't really remember
that but like watching this new series I
might be heard of it pin 15 mm-hmm
it's just two girls who like are 30
they're our age but they're playing
middle schoolers so everyone else in the
cast there like legit 12 year olds but
they're trying that every episode is
like like going through puberty or
having a crush or trying to fit into
that group and so the third episode was
about the girl becoming horny and she's
and it was funny because it's like a
spoiler alert whatever it's like the
opening shot it's like it's a close-up
on her butt like she's wearing pants
it's agrigento it's like it's like
beating and I was watching my girlfriend
and she was like this that's so [ __ ]
funny and weird but that's exactly how
it feels like oh really and then I had I
talked to it like my classmates in the
acting class they're like yeah pen15
that episode like that's exactly how I
was like so so weird like and from then
and she's like you know humping her
pillow and like touching stuff in front
of the mirror and just like really
trying to find her sexuality and so it's
just kind of like well is this dancing a
good way of expressing that I don't know
like I'm so [ __ ] confused I still
find it what I felt first of all not
that girls masturbate to I was like what
[ __ ] how you don't got a dick you stroke
I masturbate to what yeah we got dicks
so you have urges like that I thought I
had to bring that [ __ ] out of you I
didn't know that no they you want sex -
that was one of those like was the sex
then no this is just talking to girls in
la we masturbate as I do you do we
thought you [ __ ] yeah don't tell me
you take a poop we got two hoes it's
like I she blew my mind I remember that
yeah
growing up as a kid we just don't know
[ __ ]
we just know that we feel a funny way
and then we had to figure it out
specifically in my family my parents
never talk to me my any of that [ __ ]
yeah Sammy didn't talk to me about any
form of sexual education and I think my
dad never talked to me about like sexual
predators coming after me which kind of
makes me sad which means that he knew I
was under desirable he was about right
off yeah I never I never had that
conversation the birds and bees yeah I'm
trying to figure out and I can't even
pinpoint when I started figuring out
about sex like I don't know yeah because
I didn't have that conversation with my
parents I just knew that because I went
to I grew up in a church I just knew
that if I had sex I would explode like
if I stuck my penis into a vagina I
would just explode baby what just
happened
yeah do you remember in elementary
school they used to say there was that
rumor if you held somebody's hand you
would get you would have a baby or
something you said they would say they
would say that [ __ ] to scare you off and
having like kids or like a girlfriend I
am never a bit but Bart told me about so
that's like a parallel that we had with
our with our childhoods I guess I can
his school when he was younger and they
said that too so Bart would always try
to hold hands with girls just so he
could get them pregnant [ __ ] little
permit never but it was say some stuff
about him as a child I'm like dude I'm
surprised they're not doing a doc you
I'm [ __ ] around Barstow innocent yeah
but it's such a weird thing oh [ __ ]
well that was an hour oh [ __ ] yeah that
was a straight-up hour or so maybe even
a little less maybe like 50 minutes
though we got some monsters
you got anything anyways guys
yeah man this was a hot topic and you
know we had to do this one if you guys
have any suggestions about stuff that
you guys want us to talk about current
events topics advice leave that in the
comments below on the youtubes and you
can find us on Spotify you can find us
on iTunes podcast stitcher Cass buys
whatever you could think of I don't
think we on soundcloud though but we got
like 30 other options so check us out
there Cleve boy where can they find you
yeah you find me on instagram Khalif
Boyd and Twitter
hey underscore California all right job
well that concludes this episode we'll
see ya next time and just to say to jury
just just yo come in all the way
[Music]
what was your first natural sunlight you
downloaded it was definitely a boy stur
mints on how am I was remember the time
oh really yeah give them a little there
you go I missed you know what
it's really sad though my favorite
Michael Jackson song is really it is Oh
especially when they get to that part
where they harm no tell me why Dan now
has a brainwashing song yep anyways guys
next time peace peace